now this is eight news now live at 6 30
live local now a company that places
teachers from abroad into classrooms
across the country is looking now to
break its contract with the Clark County
School District thanks for staying with
us here at 6 30. I'm Denise Valdez and
I'm Brian Loftus they cite student
performance but the district is pushing
back and has filed a lawsuit to prevent
that eight news now education reporter
Joshua peguero explains
green heart International sponsors teach
us from abroad with the J-1 Visa these
teachers fill a critical role in schools
especially at CCSD where there is a
shortage of Educators so the potential
of ending that contract is creating
uncertainty lauro Escalon has a J-1
teacher from the Philippines who is
sponsored by a different company other
than green hearts there are some
trainings here that I have never
attended in the Philippines so it's it's
actually an opportunity on my part
especially on the technology side and
then on the classroom management he says
he finds the work at CCSD very enriching
and wishes federal and state lawmakers
would make it easier for international
teachers to work here as a way to
address the teacher shortage I think
they need to really look more
Beyond on how J1 can be of that of one
of the many solutions a few of
escalona's colleagues however are
nervous whether they'll even have a job
in August and the lawsuit filed last
month Clark County Schools is claiming
that green heart is trying to end its
contract with CCSD based on flawed data
well if I put my place on their
situation of course I would really feel
the same the suit reads that in May
Greenheart advised all J-1 teachers they
could not continue to work in their
current schools next school year
claiming that the public schools are not
accredited in its response to District
says the star ratings relied on by green
heart have not been updated in five
years in our base on 2018 data CCSD goes
on to say green heart has not imposed
the same requirements on teachers its
sponsors across the country Greenheart
has 68 International teachers working in
CCSD the company allegedly sent a
directive to teachers based at 10 high
schools which in includes Cheyenne El
Dorado Legacy Mojave Valley Western and
Sunrise Mountain schools that we
previously reported where CCSD police
have issued the most criminal citations
back to you
now CCSD has a policy of not commenting
on pending litigation and Greenheart
International did not respond to our
request for comment